>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Stephen Winick:
Welcome, everyone.
My name is Steve Winick and I
am the writer and editor here
in the American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress
and I'm here to welcome
you to the latest
in our homegrown concert series.
And the homegrown concert series
was created to showcase the best
of music and dance that is
homegrown in communities
across the United States.
And this is kind of an
unusual concert in the series
because usually we hold them at
noon in the Coolidge Auditorium.
And we work with state
folk arts coordinators
to help us program the series
and this is a little
bit different.
It's an evening concert,
of course,
and it's a very special
presentation
of a multimedia event with
Jeff and Gerret Warner.
And it's a program that's called
From the Mountains to Sea,
the Anne and Frank
Warner Collection.
The Anne and Frank
Warner Collection is one
of the great treasures
of the American Folklife
Center archive.
We're really very pleased
to have this collection.
And it's got beautiful
recordings of all kinds.
The ones that are probably
the most famous are the ones
from North Carolina,
including the recording
from Frank Proffitt
singing Tom Dooley
which became a gigantic hit for
the Kingston Trio in the 1950's
and they will talk about
that in the presentation.
So I should do some
housekeeping.
I should say that one of
the reasons that we're able
to hold this evening
concert is co-sponsorship
by the Folklore Society
of Greater Washington,
which is also known as FSGW.
FSGW is a membership
organization dedicated
to preserving and
presenting folk arts
in the Washington D.C. region
and you can find out more
about them on the outside.
And you can also find recordings
of the artists at
the table outside.
And we're going to ask you if
you want to buy those recordings
and books and other
things from the artists,
please do so at the
intermission because we do have
to clear the building pretty
quickly after the concert.
So we'd like to make sure
that there's time to
get everybody out.
So please try to do your
purchasing at the intermission
and we really hope that
you will want to take some
of this music home with you.
One more piece of housekeeping,
we love mobile phones,
we really do.
In fact, the Veteran's
History Project even has an app
that you can use your mobile
phone to record oral histories.
But we would like you to turn
your mobile phones off during
the concert because this is all
being documented for a webcast.
And so there's a film crew
here and it's being documented
on audio as well and we don't
want our phones to ring.
So please turn off
your cell phones.
And so I mentioned that this is
a wonderful presentation called
From the Mountains
to Sea about the Anne
and Frank Warner Collection.
And we are here to welcome
Jeff and Gerret Warner
and they are going to join
me on stage for just a moment
with a magical object
before they begin the music
and the presentation.
And so Jeff Warner,
Gerret Warner.
And I'm going to
invite up on the stage
as well, Betsy Peterson.
She is the director of the
American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Thank you,
Steve and welcome
to everyone here.
I'm up here to accept
a wonderful gift
from Jeff and Gerret Warner.
They're going to give something
to the American Folklife Center
and so I just wondered if you
could tell us a little bit
about this beautiful instrument.
>> Jeff Warner: This was
made by Nathan Hicks,
who was a mountain
man in Watauga County.
You're seeing his
picture as we speak.
It was made for Frank
Warner in 1939.
And it has a -- my
father was doing a program
in New York City singing
songs of the Hudson River.
And he took his brand-new
banjo that he had with him.
And was sitting, found
himself sitting right next
to the poet Carl Sandburg.
And on a whim, he said to Carl,
"Would you sign the head?"
Carl Sandburg signed
the head, dated at 1939.
And my father said,
"After that it was easy
to get other people to sign it."
>> Gerret Warner: So
there are 265 signatures
that were added beyond that,
including Woody Guthrie,
Pete Seeger, Alan
and John Lomax.
>> Jeff Warner: Led Belly.
Yeah, it's great.
And we had a wonderful
time talking
about it with Steve today.
So much so that my brother
and I said, "You know,
we really love this banjo.
Maybe we should keep
it, you know."
>> Elizabeth Peterson: No, no.
>> Gerret Warner: It looks
even more attractive now.
>> Jeff Warner: Right?
But no. We decided in our
wisdom, this goes to the Library
of Congress and we're happy that
it goes to the American people
with all the names
from the folk revival
and folk [inaudible]
from 1939 to 1977.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Thank you, so much.
>> Gerret Warner: Thank you.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Thank you, so much.
This is a wonderful gift and
to have a beautiful banjo made
by Nathan Hicks, played by
your father Frank Warner,
and on behalf of the Library of
Congress, and I know everyone
at the American Folklife Center.
I'm pleased to accept this.
We will cherish it, take care
of it, and I want to thank Jeff
and Gerret Warner for
this beautiful instrument.
And also want to thank
Anne and Frank Warner
for their amazing collection,
which they have bestowed
to the American people and
given to us to take care of it.
And we will do our
very, very best.
Please come and see it.
But now I'm going to turn
everything over to Jeff
and Gerret Warner for From
the Mountains to Sea, the Anne
and Frank Warner
Collection so please enjoy.
>> Jeff Warner: Thank
you, Betsy.
[ Music ]
>> Jeff Warner: Frank Warner
collected that song in 1952
at a conference in Cleveland,
Ohio but the story leading up to
that is long and full.
So you go do your work.
>> Gerret Warner:
I have to work now.
All right.
[ Music ]
>> Jeff Warner: Friday
June 3rd, 1938.
We left New York at 6:50 P.M and
drove over the Pulaski Skyway
with a wonderful
flaming Sunset overhead.
Found ourselves in real
country in 20 minutes.
Through Lambertville,
New Jersey just at dusk
and wished we could stay.
Lovely old-fashioned village.
So on through the Pennsylvania
Hills under the moon
on to some extra nice
cabins beyond Coatesville,
Drake's Spanish Court.
They were nice too.
Even a good bed.
That was from my mother,
Anne Warner's journal
on the first day.
The first day of Anne and Frank
Warner's journey to a world
of old songs, old ways,
and new friendships.
To their unexpected but gladly
accepted role as preserver
of song of American memory.
Their journey to the
mountains from the sea.
Alan Lomax said, "The Warners
mind the most pristine American
song terrain, the
Eastern seaboard,
where the old songs
still retain the flavor
of England, Scotland
and Ireland.
And where the new
American songs grew
in very spring time
of the national saga.
We have Anne's early young girl
diaries, her thoughts and poems.
And her young woman
notebooks of news events
and spiritual seeking.
And now she decided to keep
a journal as a couple set
out to meet Appalachian mountain
man Nathan Hicks, who had agreed
to make them a lap dulcimer.
Saturday June 4th, 1938.
"We seem destined to spend the
night in Pulaski, Virginia.
Which we reached just
about 8 P.M. We what
about to see the sights,
it being Saturday night.
Stopped to listen to an
exhortation by a young preacher
with a fanatical countenance
who was holding forth
at a tent revival.
He didn't seem to
be doing so well
for we didn't see
anyone come forward.
Though he came down and argued
with individuals in
the congregation."
Anne Locher was born in St.
Louis in 1905 and raised
in Saint Paul in Chicago.
Frank Warner was born
into the deep south
of Selma, Alabama in 1903.
And raised in Durham,
North Carolina.
In the 30's because of work
and financial necessity,
they found themselves in New
York City, met and married.
But they didn't have
kids for a while.
Anne had to leave
Northwestern University in 1925
after her sophomore year to help
support her parents in New York.
But she was happy, despite the
hardships of the depression,
to find herself a newly
married woman in 1938.
Living in Greenwich
Village amidst literary
and artistic greats
and near greats
in an intellectually
stimulating community.
From what she told my
brother Gerret and me,
Frank Warner was not one
of the intellectually
stimulating near-greats
but she grew to love
him nonetheless.
Sunday June 5th, 1938, "We
started out about 7 A.M.
on a beautiful morning and got
into the mountains
almost at once.
We crossed the Carolina
state line in about 70 miles.
Carolina in the morning.
We reached Boone toward noon.
To our amazement,
the town was crowded
with people the streets
lined with old cars
and trucks and wagons.
How the gods smile on us.
We had happened on
a county sing.
[ Music ]
We worked our way up
to the courthouse.
Its front yard and porch
were filled with people.
By degrees, we got upstairs
and into the courtroom
where the sing was in process.
A mixed group was
singing when we came in.
About 12, old and young.
And when they finished,
another group came up
but there was no applause.
Hardly a change of expression."
[ Music ]
"The next group was
a male quartet.
The tenor who took the lead
sang entirely through a nose,
hardly opening his mouth.
A young girl in the audience
bent down to hide her face
and laugh and came up
again without even a smile.
I don't think I've ever
been stared at as we were
in Boone that morning.
We must have had an
obviously foreign look."
Frank Warner grew up in
the south as a hunter,
a football player, and
eventually a YMCA executive.
He was also a singer.
A talented ukulele player,
he was known in college
as the big man with
a little instrument.
He organized an award-winning
quartet,
led the Duke University
glee club and was one
of the students asked
to sing ballads
to illustrate classes
given by noted professor
and folk song collector,
Frank C Brown.
It took Frank Warner six years
to get his degree from Duke,
but he used the time
wisely, being a campus
and assistant dean, an
adviser to underclassmen.
After university he
moved to Greensboro,
North Carolina organizing
camps for the YMCA,
and singing on WBIG
in the evening.
He sang folk songs,
minstrel songs,
ballads for the Brown
collection and popular songs
of the day Paul Whiteman's
Rhythm Boys with Bing Crosby.
He was a big man with a warm
voice and a welcoming spirit.
He was equally at home
with old country folk
or the wealthy members
of his Long Island YMCA
board of directors.
I remembered being
backstage with him before one
of his more important concerts,
asking, "Aren't you nervous?"
He said, "Why should
I be nervous?
They are only people."
Sunday June 5th, 1938, "From
Boone we took a state road
to Vilas and Valle
Crucis and went up and up
and up for nearly 10 miles.
And then the dirt road
Nathan Hicks spoke of,
it was really nothing
but a wagon road.
Just wide enough for one car.
It wound up, straight
up sometimes,
it took 45 minutes
to go 5 miles."
When seeking directions
once from a mountain local,
our parents were told to keep
driving up until they went
around the bend where they could
see their own license plate.
Then they'd be there.
"At last we could see the Hicks'
house down in a little cove.
And then we saw Nathan
in a shirt and tie.
He said he was sure
pleased to see us.
And we went down into
the house which seemed
to be overflowing with people."
[ Music ]
There, Anne and Frank
met the Hicks family.
Nathan, and Nelle, the
youngest of their 13 children.
And much of the Hicks' extended
family and many neighbors.
People who had come to see
these visitors from the beyond.
The hardships were evident
with no running water,
or electricity, or money
to buy necessities.
The Warners waked into the house
to see a couple of cots covered
by people sitting on them
with a few rickety chairs.
Reena Hicks said, "I
couldn't hardly believe you'd
really come."
When the Warners were asked to
sit down, Reena said to Anne,
"Them chairs ain't very good."
Frank Warner said,
"I have to be careful
when I sit down in any chair."
Nathan asked him how
much he did weigh.
Frank Warner said, "You guess."
And Nathan guessed exactly
to everyone's delight.
Frank said, "I can see
you been weighing hogs."
As my mother told me the last
shreds of her strength vanished.
The rest of the day and
evening were spent learning
about each other and in song.
[ Music ]
Through friends in that
interesting 1938 Greenwich
Village community, the
Warners met Maurice Madison,
who had been collecting ballads
and songs on Beech Mountain,
North Carolina the year before.
He showed the Warners
a lap dulcimer made
for him by Nathan Hicks.
The Warners had never seen one,
few in New York had at the time.
The Warners wanted one
and wrote to Nathan
if he would make a
dulcimer for them.
Nathan wrote back, "Dear Mr.
Warner, I received your letter
that you wanted the
dulcimer like Mr. Madison.
I can't send in unless
I get some money.
As postage and glue and nails
cost me money and times is
so hard and my wife is
sick most of the time.
And we have 10 children
and the times is so hard,
I can't get much money.
Please send me the money
and I'll have the dulcimer
read time I hear from you.
Your friend, Nathan Hicks."
fatefully, thankfully, Anne
and Frank decided to drive
down to Beech Mountain when
the dulcimer was ready instead
of waiting for the mail.
Or else instead of a thousand
songs here at the Library
of Congress, scores of
historic photographs and years
of expressive correspondence
from rural friends,
we would have a single
mountain dulcimer
on the way, which
we have anyway.
[ Music ]
The people on Beech
Mountain lived
in 1938 not very much
differently form the Scotts
Irish settlers who moved
into those North Carolina,
Tennessee mountains
in the 18th century.
And when the Warners drove
down to meet their new friends,
it was only 20 years
after Cecil Sharp
and Maud Karpeles had made
their momentous journeys
into these same Appalachian
Mountains.
[ Music ]
There on the beach the
Warners met Buena Vista Hicks,
Aunt Bueny, who played
a fiddle handmade
by her husband Roby back inside
a single piece dug out of a log.
Aunt Bueny, who saying in
that clear wild mountain style
on the edge of her voice.
And who started to play at
local festivals in the 1960's
when she was in her late 70's.
They met one of Nathan's
sons, Louis, who when told
that there were one million
people in New York City,
he said, "I reckon if
that many folks took
out after you they'd
sure catch you."
And Nathan and Reena's
young son, Ray Hicks,
who would later be recognized
as a master story teller.
And in 1983, given a
National Heritage Fellowship
by the National Endowment
for the Arts.
And they met Nathan's young
son-in-law, a carpenter
and tobacco farmer,
Frank Proffitt.
[ Music ]
Frank Proffitt was born in 1913.
After 6th grade at a
mountain school he left school
to work on his father's farm.
Then in the 1930's, left
home for the first time
to join the Works Progress
Administration, the WPA,
one of the many programs
designed during the depression
by the Roosevelt administration
to get America working again.
When the Warners met Frank, he
had been away from the beach.
Some had heard radio and was
under the thrall
of Jimmie Rodgers.
And why not?
But he always valued the
older songs he'd learned
from his father Wiley, from
his Aunt Nancy Prather,
and from his grandfather
John Proffitt,
who crossed enemy lines
to fight for the Union
with the 13th Tennessee
Cavalry during the Civil War.
Frank Proffitt sang
the Warners three songs
on that first day they met.
Dan Doo, Moonshine,
and Tom Dooley.
Later on in 1941, when the
Warners stayed with Frank
and his wife Bessy
for several days,
the Warners had a portable
recording machine made
for them by Filco Electronics.
There at the house
that Frank built,
the Warners recorded Tom
Dooley and the beginnings
of 100 song repertoire from
Proffitt's mountain past.
Frank Warner was moved
by the song Tom Dooley.
He took it back to New
York where he sang it
for collector Alan Lomax,
who included the song
in his 1947 book folks on USA.
The song and the book made
its way around America.
And in 1958 was recorded by
a west coast singing group,
the Kingston Trio, who sold
three million copies of the song
and in doing so helped to
generate the folk song revival
which continues on a
half century later.
The story of the
Dooley recording is long
and for another time.
But Lomax's publisher and the
Kingston Trio's capital records
settled a suit out
of court in 1962.
And from that settlement,
Frank Proffitt made enough
to build a new house
there in Watauga County.
[ Music ]
Tom Dooley was the story of
a real murder that took place
in 1868 where Tom Dula,
D-U-L-A, pronounced Dooley
in the mountains, came back from
the Civil War, got himself more
than one girlfriend, and
then handled it badly.
He was hanged for the
murder of Laura Foster.
Over the years, Frank Proffitt
changed the way he changed
the song.
We don't know if it was the
influence of Frank Warner,
the Kingston Trio, or
just his personal choice.
[ Music ]
Tom Dooley did something
else for Frank Proffitt.
It allowed him to travel
far form his mountain top
and meet thousands of people
interested in him and his music.
World War II interrupted the
Warners' collecting trips.
When they finally got a car
and the time, they went back
to the mountains in 1951.
And this time with
two small children.
I stand amazed how
they did that.
Dragging an 8 and a 5 year old
into the 19th century
mountain life.
When they got to the beach,
they found Frank
Proffitt was not there.
Hard times had caused him
to sell his instruments
and go off to find work.
He had stopped singing.
The 1951 sessions, Gerret's
and my first in the mountains,
yielded much important material
because now the Warners
had a tape recorder.
There were long interviews
with Roby and Bueny Hicks
and a Jack Tale from
Rey and an afternoon
with the preacher [inaudible].
But Frank Proffitt was missed.
[ Music ]
The 1950's moved on.
The Warners raising two sons
and holding down their jobs
on Long Island in New York but
planted seeds were growing.
When Frank Proffitt saw the
Kingston Trio sing Tom Dooley
on television sometime
in the late '50s,
he thought they were making
fun of him and his music.
Frank Warner had to go down
to North Carolina to meet
with Proffitt and assure him
that he was not being mocked.
Reluctantly, Proffitt
agreed to go with Warner
to the 1961 Chicago
folk festival.
Frank Warner said that
Proffitt was so nervous,
he couldn't go on stage.
So Warner had the crew turn
on all the stage lights
so Proffitt couldn't
see the audience.
And then he went out on
stage with Frank Proffitt
to ease him into singing.
It worked.
Reviewer Studd Sterkle said,
"Frank Proffitt, the farmer
and carpenter from North
Carolina told us more
than we have accustomed
to expect.
Since a great many of us have
come to equate folk music
with cuteness, cleverness,
pretty sounds.
But often folk song --
folk singing is not pretty
and sometimes it is harsh
as life itself is hard.
Always it is true."
There was a singular reaction
at the three-day festival.
The audience, consisting
primarily of college students,
acclaimed the Appalachian man
rather than the slick pros.
In 1964, Proffitt
accompanied Warner
to the new for folk festival.
And then he represented
the state of North Carolina
at the World's Fair
in New York City.
Frank Proffitt recorded
three albums of his music
for folk legacy and folk
wave Smithsonian and began
to get orders for his handmade
banjos from around the world.
I have one of those banjos,
made for me by Frank shortly
before he died suddenly
at the age of 52.
I'll show it to you sometime.
I played another of Frank's
banjos in Peter Kennedy's parlor
in Gloucester, England in 2004.
Frank's music got around and now
I'm glad to say that banjo is
in the reading room right here
at the Library of Congress.
That same one that Frank made
for Douglas Kennedy back in '61.
At age 16, Frank Proffitt
walked barefoot across the hills
to his first town,
Mountain City, Tennessee.
In his short life, Frank moved
from 18th century subsistence
farming to deserved recognition
of sophistication
of the 20th century.
Playing at festivals, making
commercial recordings,
taking orders for sought
after handmade banjos,
and corresponding with
people from around the world.
My mother said, "Frank Proffitt
was a generous, sensitive,
uncommonly intelligent stubborn
and often full of humor man.
I love Frank's sense of humor.
Speaking of farming his
North Carolina mountains,
he said he was plowing
a hill so steep
that he kept getting
dirt down his collar."
He met a man once, said Frank,
sitting by the side
of the road crying.
Frank asked him,
"What was the matter?"
He said, "That's the
fourth time today I fell
out of my cornfield."
During that first trip
to the mountains in 1938,
Frank and the Hicks' and the
Warners' had climbed the behind
Hicks' house to get a
grand look, take pictures,
and show everyone
binoculars for the first time.
Frank Proffitt said he
could see his cornfield
through the glasses.
And then with one of
his rare smiles said,
"I don't see nobody
hoeing in it though."
[ Laughter ]
Even I can remember
Frank's humor
at the Newport Folk
Festival in 1964,
he saw Earl Scruggs
playing banjo.
Fast. Frank Proffitt said,
"I'd like to be able to play
that way and then not."
[ Laughter ]
In 1959, Frank wrote
to the Warners,
"My earliest recollection is of
waking on a cold winter morning
in a log cabin on
the old beaver dam.
And hearing the sad
haunting tune of Tom Dooley,
picked by my father along
with the frying of meat
on the little step
stove, and the noise
of the little coffee mill
grinding the arbuckle.
What better world could there be
for a small boy who was hungry
for the fried meat and biscuit
and hungry also to make sounds
like a grown up on a
curly walnut banjo.
I started soon to
trying to pick the banjo.
And soon the happy day
came when dad said,
"I declare you are just about
got Tom Dooley a going."
I married into another
singing family of Nathan Hicks
and with his dulcimer I went
on to the kind of
life that I loved.
Then Frank Warner
came to the mountains
and in him I saw
an educated person
who made me feel like somebody.
I open my heart to him and
gave him all the old songs
of my people.
His eyes sparkled as I sing
Tom Dooley to him and told him
of my grandma Proffitt
knowing Tom and Laura.
I've told him of people and he
and Anne didn't seem to notice
that we was poor and
didn't know any big words.
They bragged on our new calf,
on our little two room cabin.
Brought us store stuff to eat.
I walked on airs for day --
I walked on air for
days after they left.
I got a television
set for the kids
and one night I was a set
looking at some foolishness
when three fellers stepped
out with a guitar and a banjo
and went to singing Tom Dooley.
And they clowed and
they hip swinged.
I began to feel sort of sick.
Like I'd lost a loved one.
I went out and I
balled on the ridge.
Looking towards old Wilkes
County, land of Tom Dooley.
I looked up across the
mountains and I said, "Lord,
couldn't they leave
me the good memories?"
But then Frank Warner wrote,
he tells me that someway
our song got picked up.
The shock was over,
I went back to work.
I begin to see the
world was bigger
than our mountains
or Wilkes or Watauga.
Folks was brothers.
I began to pit them that hadn't
dozed by the hearthstone.
Life was sharing the different
thinking, the different ways.
I looked in the mirror
of my heart.
You ain't a boy no longer.
Give folks like Frank
Warner all you got.
Quit thinking ridge to ridge.
Think ocean to ocean."
[ Music ]
That's a perfect
place to take a break.
But we couldn't make it
that way so you're going
to have to deal with it.
Soon. Soon we will.
A note about the times in which
Anne and Frank Warner lived.
Mike Seager said to me once,
"Up until 100 years ago,
if you ever heard music
it was played by someone
in the same room as you.
Then in the 20's came
radio and with the flick
of a switch it ended loneliness.
We never thought to ask our
parents what it must have been
like to live in a
time without radio.
Then see it become universal.
But in the late 1930's as
they were soon to find out,
there were pockets of the
country where electricity
and radios had yet to come.
And it was the depression.
Artists and writers were
affected by the plight
of the common man and
had been put to work
by the Roosevelt Administration.
The Federal Writers' Project
hired more than 6,000 people
to write state guidebooks
and collect folk lore
and oral histories.
James Agee and Let Us
Now Praise Famous Men,
his book length essay about
three families of tenant farmers
in Alabama, used photographs
by the farm security
administration's Walker Evans.
Virgil Thompson composed scores
for government documentaries.
And WPA painters created
murals celebrating pioneers
and working people.
Steinbeck's Grapes of Wrath
grew out of the reporting he did
for the FSA on hunger and health
in California migrant camps.
In 1939, Aaron Copland wrote
film scores for Our Town
and the Academy Award
nominated Of Mice and Men.
And he was working on his
fanfare for the common man.
In New York, the Warners'
friends were writing
about heartland America
and portraying country
people and their lives.
Stephen Vincent Benet
wrote Western Star,
the Pulitzer Prize
winning book length poem
about the pioneers of America.
Carl Carmer, historian,
author and upstairs neighbor,
wrote the best-selling Stars
Fell on Alabama in 1934.
Created nonfiction about the
people on folklore of Alabama.
1938, the timing was perfect.
Two people, Anne, a born
historian and writer.
Frank, a natural singer
and engaging southerner,
setting out while the
old song still lingered.
Encouraged by their literary
friends to find American
and setting out when
recorded sound away
from a studio had
become possible.
First, the publishers Farrar
& Rinehart then Filco,
pioneers in radio and television
manufacture, became interested
in the Warners collecting trips.
They developed disc makers that
could be taken into the field.
Those machines and the tape
recorder that followed in 1951,
made possible the thousand
songs found by the Warners
that now reside at the
Library of Congress.
[ Music ]
In the late 1930s, Carl
Carmer, their upstairs neighbor,
was working on a history of
the Hudson River and its lore.
In its research he came across
a long-retired Adirondack logger
named John Galusha
of Minerva, New York.
Carl decided the Warners should
go visit John, so they did,
one week in the summer of 1939.
That began an ongoing
relationship with John
that lasted until he died
in 1950 at the age of 91.
He was a reluctant
singer at first.
Another collector had found
John some years before,
noted down a raft of
songs, and then left
without further communication.
But John became sure quickly
that would not be the
case with the Warners.
John Galusha was of Irish
descent born in 1859.
his grandfather fought
in the war of 1812.
He started working in
the North woods in 1875.
The need for wood was enormous
in the late 19th century
to build and heat houses for
the ties of limitless miles
of railroad track, and
the Adirondacks were,
as one commentator put it,
the Saudi Arabia of Wood.
Chopping, hauling,
stacking timber all winter.
Then in the spring, driving
the logs down the Hudson River
to mills at Glens Falls.
That's the way John lived.
[ Music ]
John's singing style was
decided northern and reflective
of his Irish heritage and the
many Irish Americans who worked
in the lumber camps with him.
He was not the highly
decorated Irish Shaun O style,
but an open, declarative
northern Irish storytelling
style that delivered
both text and emotion.
I think of Irish singer Joe
Heaney, long living in America,
who used to say, "You tell the
story and you say the song.
And a song should have
a pulse but not a beat."
[ Music ]
John's older brother died of
wounds he received at the battle
of Battle of Cold Harbor
in Virginia in 1864.
The Civil War was
most real to him.
Frank Warner did not talk much
about his own upbringing
in the south.
John Galusha said, "I
knew a rebel colonel,
I guided him fishing.
Every time I looked at him,
I thought of my brother lying
on his bed groaning and
I wanted to kill him.
I didn't like him.
But he was an all right fellow.
The southern people are
a generous race of people
if you can believe what you read
and what other people tell you."
[ Laughter ]
[ Music ]
Through Carl Carmer, the
Warners also a singer
in New Hampshire,
my adopted state.
Her name was Helena Lima.
Born Fish, Grammy Fish.
She was born in 1873
into a logging family
in the Black Brook section
of Northern Adirondacks.
Moving to New Hampshire in
her early '20s to take a job
as a housekeeper for a midwife.
Then she married her
employer's son, John Fish,
and raised a large family
in the temple Jeffrey
section of the state.
When the Warners first knocked
in her door of the summer
of 1940 saying, "We
heard you were interested
in old time songs."
She said, "Come right in."
My folks said she chased the
grand kids out of the house
and was soon singing and
was not to be stopped.
Her off spring cared little
for her homely old songs
and sentimental poems.
She was so happy to have
someone visit her who cared.
In two long weekends
in 1940 and '41
and sang almost 100
songs to the Warners.
Out of memory without
reading music.
Helen Hartness Flanders
a Vermont collector
in the 40's also
visited Mrs. Fish.
She too got 100 songs from
Fish of which 50 are different.
I visit Lina's granddaughter,
Ruth Quin, whenever I'm
out in Temple, New Hampshire.
As a matter of fact, two
years ago I got to go
to her 90th birthday party.
She said the Warners'
and Flanders' visits did
wonders for her grandmother.
She took a new interest in
life, collected more stories
about local history, and started
distributing a little mimeograph
newsletter about her songs.
Collected and even a
few written by Lina.
She even began to sing
out for local societies
and civic organizations.
There are many members of
the extended Fish family
in southern New Hampshire.
Every five years or so they have
a big gathering, a Fish fry.
A few years ago, they -- I got
voted on as an honorary Fish
and I went to the fry and got
to sing some of Lina's songs
to her great-great-grand kids.
She would have been pleased.
Anne and Frank Warner
entered into the field
of folk song collection as
enthusiastic untutored amateurs.
They both had full time
jobs and were lucky
to have a few weeks each summer
to be out looking for songs.
They had none of the training,
grants, or university support
that was to come later
to some folklorists.
Anne and Frank always wished
they'd asked Grammy Fish
where she learned her songs.
But they didn't know
enough to ask at the time.
The Warners developed their
own style of collecting.
Befriend, share stories, offer
a list of motifs that are
in old songs designed
to spur memory.
Like Milk White Steed's
Castle Gates,
Three Times Around,
We Pen Knives.
If that didn't work, just
keep singing songs at them
until they couldn't take it
anymore and they'd sing back.
Then record a verse and chorus
while Anne took down the balance
of words in shorthand.
That worked for them until they
started lecturing and writing
about these remarkable
singers and their songs.
Then they wished they had
learned more about provenance
about these fine
tradition bearers.
[ Music ]
Grammy's repertoire was far
ranging, including child ballads
like Lord Bateman Lady Isabel
and the Elf Knight
which you just heard.
And songs like The Bonny Bay
of Biscay-O found elsewhere
in America but we
don't think so.
And even in the U.K. I can't
find any record of that song.
Here's what Mrs. Fish sang.
[ Music ]
Her repertoire included
songs from American history
and from the 19th century stage
like All the Little Chickens
in the Garden and
The Jolly Roving Tar.
[ Music ]
And Lina's repertoire included
a lot of funny songs from the,
of the humor of the
late 19th century.
[ Music ]
That may be the only time
in your life you
ever sing that song.
Well let me guarantee that the
second half is a lot shorter
than the first.
That's the way we
had to make it work.
We could tell you why
but it would be even more
boring if we told you why.
So we're going to have -- we've
got another little section.
I mean, just a paragraph
by Lina in her own writing.
And we're going to take a break.
I've got my extended
family for generations
out there handling
the sales table.
What you've got, Tim
Ericson, in 1998 decided
that we should publish
this Warner collection.
And so he arranged with
Appleseed Record, his publisher
at the time, to produce
two albums.
So Gerret, my brother Gerret
and I listened for a whole year
to the collection and
pulled out two albums
of these singers singing
these historic songs.
And those are there.
Also a mailing list
for me because I'm
around all the time
singing these old songs.
If you're interested we'll
be out there talking too.
We have a book of songs Lina
put together mimeographed.
The introduction, written
in her own hand says,
"With what tender memories
my heart was filled
as I wrote down these old songs.
As you review the songs of long
ago I think you will find they
will compare favorably
in both rhythm and rhyme
to modern song and verse.
May they fill many hearts
with tender memories
of childhood is the sincere
wish of Lina born Fish.
[ Music ]
In 1951, Gerret's and my
first trip to Beech Mountain.
The trip where Frank Proffitt
had sold his instruments
and had gone off to
find work, that trip.
The Warners met Lee Monroe
Presnell, Bueny Hicks' uncle.
Born in 1876, he was the
grandson of Council Harmon,
legendary Watauga County
singer and storyteller.
Lee Monoe became a preacher.
Finest preacher you
ever heard, said Bueny.
The interview you'll hear
shortly was recorded in 1951.
Frank Warner and
Lee Monroe Presnell.
[ Music ]
>> Frank Warner: Good
morning, Mr. Presnell.
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
Good morning.
>> Frank Warner:
How are you, sir?
>> Lee Monroe Presnell: Coming.
>> Frank Warner: Coming?
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
Yes, sir.
>> Frank Warner: Everything
nice day at the big rain.
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
[Inaudible], sir.
>> Frank Warner:
Settle things down.
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
Yes, sir.
>> Frank Warner: How about
telling me about you?
I'm interested in knowing
about you and your folks.
>>Lee Monroe Presnell:
I was [inaudible].
I have represented -- tried
to represent the old
[inaudible] for about 42 years.
>> Frank Warner: Is that so.
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
Yes, sir.
And I'm a getting feeble.
I'm a getting old.
But at the same time
I've got a hope.
>> Frank Warner: Amen?
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
Yes, sir.
>> Frank Warner: Amen.
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
I've got the good hope.
>> Frank Warner: Yes, sir.
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
And I stay on the furs
of the Beech Mountain with
eyes fresh and healthy.
And a [inaudible] and I'm glad
that the good Lord has blessed
me and kept me until this spread
in time and for that purpose
I don't know why I'm here.
But it's on purpose.
>> Frank Warner:
There's a good reason.
>> Lee Monroe Presnell:
Yes, sir.
Some good reason
[ Music ]
>> Mr. [inaudible], I'm going to
sing you a little spiritual now.
Nobody Knew Him.
[ Music ]
>> Jeff Warner: Through Frank --
through Frank Warner grew
up in the segregated south,
he had friends in
the black community
from his earliest days.
As a young man he had met
a woman who was a cook
at a fisherman's boarding house
in Nags Head on the Outer Banks.
She was Sue Thomas of
Elizabeth City, North Carolina.
Anne and Frank visited with her,
sang with her before
they were married
and before they knew they were
interested in song gathering.
Once they knew, they
went back to see her.
Sue Thomas had many fine gospel
songs including He's Got The
Whole World In His
Hand, which Sue
and then Frank Warner were
singing long before Marian
Anderson or Lonnie
Donegan recorded it.
Long before it was song around
every campfire in America.
She also sang a song
Frank Warner used
to close his programs,
Hold My Hand Lord Jesus.
>> Sue Thomas: Mr. [inaudible],
I want to sing you a favorite
song, Hold My Hand Lord Jesus.
[ Music ]
>> Jeff Warner: One of the
trips down to see Sue Thomas,
Anne and Frank stopped
overnight and Suffolk, Virginia.
Which is, unsurprisingly, just
south of Norfolk, Virginia.
At Suffolk, at the Elliott
Cafe, they were waited
on by an affable
young man, Bill Moss.
With whom they quickly
got into conversation.
They asked if he knew anyone in
town that knew the old songs.
He called his friend,
Jesse McDonald over
and Jesse said, "There's
uncle Joe.
He knows all them old songs."
Bill objected, "But you
know Uncle Joe is dead."
"No." Jesse said.
"He mighty low but
he ain't dead."
The Next morning, Bill
and Jesse took the Warners
to see Uncle Joe.
He was mighty low.
He had had a stroke and
was confined to bed.
He struggled to sing.
His songs, though heartfelt,
are hard to understand.
[ Music ]
Uncle Joe had had, for 50 years,
been a successful street vendor
in Suffolk, Virginia
selling peanuts in a town
where peanuts was the industry.
More importantly to him
and probably his customers,
he was also a lay preacher.
When he had enough
people gathered
around his cart eating peanuts,
he'd sing his gospel
songs and preached.
He was a loved character
in Suffolk.
He taught Frank Warner
the street cry he used
to get folks to come
to his cart.
And my father taught it to me.
He said, "Fresh peanuts.
Fresh peanuts is
the best of all.
They'd raised in the
summer and dug in the fall.
I got fresh peanuts.
One bag for nickel, one bag
for nickel, and two for a dime.
Three, 15 and all them mine.
If you don't think they're good
just buy them and try them.
I got fresh peanuts.
Raised by the hand and
parched in the pan.
I got to sell number
one if I can.
Please don't deny them
just step up and buy them.
I got fresh peanuts.
Joe Henry Johnson is my name,
selling peanuts is my game.
I got fresh peanuts.
One bag for nickel, one bag
for nickel, and two for a dime.
Three, 15 and all them mine.
If you don't think they're good
just buy them and try them.
I got fresh peanuts.
Raised by the hand and
parched in the pan.
I got to sell number
one if I can.
Please don't deny them
just step up and buy them.
I got fresh peanuts."
>> This ballad and
[inaudible] Jones.
[ Music ]
Not too far south of Suffolk,
Virginia is Roanoke Island
and the small village
of Wanchese
on the Outer Banks
of North Carolina.
Frank Warner knew
that Frank C. Brown
of Duke University had
collected songs in the 20's
from a fisherman
named Charles Tillett.
So the Warners went
to find Mr. Tillett.
They med him and his wife
Eleazar, great Bible name.
In the summer of 1940, just
as they had got their first
Wilcox-Gay recording machine.
They only had two hours with
Charles, known as Tink Tillett,
but they were great ones.
Yielding songs about Paul
Jones, which you just heard,
and Napoleon Bonaparte,
child ballads,
and even a 1917 Harry
Lauder Musical song,
There's Somebody Waiting For Me.
We'll sing that together
sometime.
>> Charles Tillett: Somebody
Waiting for Me is the name.
[ Music ]
>> Jeff Warner: The Warners
and the Tilletts expected a
happy reunion the following
summer but Tink died
suddenly in the spring of '41.
His wife, Eleazar, wrote,
inviting the Warners down.
Saying she would do the best she
could to remember Tink's songs.
Which she did very well.
The Warners went down in 1941
and many times thereafter,
beginning a relationship
with the Tillett family
that continues to this day
and allowed me to meet Eleazar
and to know her children
and grandchildren.
Eleazar born around 1870,
is one my favorite singers.
[ Music ]
In 1951, the Warners
had a tape recorder.
At the end of the session, maybe
Gerret and I were in the room,
Eleazar and Frank
Warner and Anne agreed
to resume their visits.
>> Frank Warner:
Let's make a date now
for next summer, all right.
>> Eleazar Tillett:
I may not make it.
>> Frank Warner:
Oh yes you will.
>> Eleazar Tillett: Well
we are stacked to see you.
>> Frank Warner:
Let's make it --
>> Eleazar Tillett:
[Inaudible] Jones.
>> Frank Warner:
Oh no you won't.
>> Eleazar Tillett: I'll
miss the [inaudible].
>> Frank Warner: Let's make
a date with the sisters.
Next summer and sit down and
remember the rest of them.
>> Eleazar Tillett:
If we're living.
>> Frank Warner: All right.
>> Eleazar Tillett: If only.
[ Music ]
>> Jeff Warner: One of
Eleazar's songs was Nancy Til
or Come Love Come,
a charming meld
of two 19th century
minstrel songs.
>> Anne Warner: If
you can just sing us
that much you sang,
we'd love it.
[ Music ]
>> Jeff Warner: There were
other places, other singers,
other important songs.
Found in living rooms or
in hotel dining rooms.
From interested professors,
or Jamaican women who looked
after Gerret and me in New
York City when we were babies.
Or songs from barefoot
country children.
But [inaudible] journey
together where we began it
on Beech Mountain
of North Carolina.
Take a second here to
thank a bunch of people.
And we can hold applause
until we get
through because there's
so many to recognize.
My brother Gerret who put
together the visual thing here.
It's just beautiful
from all the Frank
and Anne Warner photographs.
And my sister-in-law Mimi Gretty
who's been running the sound
tonight for the sound
of the recordings.
Chris Romaine.
The inevitable and
wonderful Chris Romaine
who loaned me his banjo so I
didn't have to fly with one.
Folklore Society of
greater Washington
who co-sponsored
tonight, thank you.
Todd Harvey of the American
Folklife Center who made
so easy the donation of this
banjo one we decided to do it.
And who I'll talk to
if we want it back.
Steve Winick, writer editor
for the Folklife Center,
for arranging and moderating the
interview we did this afternoon
and helping with the
organizing of this event.
And Thia Austin who was our
point person and worked with me
for months to get us here.
She's the public events
Folklife Center coordinator.
And she and I have worked
together before in 1993.
I was singing in
England and Bob Copper
of the famous singing Copper
family said to me, "You're going
to fix our first
tour in America."
And I said, "Okay."
And I did.
So in 1995, the Copper family
in their first trip over,
stood on this very stage in this
very room and sang the songs
from their generations of
their Sussex farmer background.
It was so funny that that first
day they came on stage here,
they looked out at the audience
and Bob Copper said,
"Where's the beer."
We end this -- in 1959,
the first mountain trip
Gerret and I -- oh.
Applause.
[ Applause ]
'59, the first mountain
trip Gerret
and I really remember,
we met Homer Cornet.
A cousin of Frank Proffitt.
He was a shy man who
sang only two songs
in the one visit
we had with him.
One was an older gospel song
he had reworked as a gift
to the Church when he joined.
It's called the Wild
Stormy Deep.
Let's listen to Homer sings
and then let's end together
by singing it together.
[ Music ]
>> Jeff Warner: Thank you.
>> Stephen Winick: Please,
another round of applause
for Jeff Warner, for Gerret
Warner, and for the whole team.
Thank you all so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.